lui qui pour vous benache aussi alors je
vous propose d exalter les deux
week-ends bien sûr comme d'habitude sauf
dieu dans cette séquence et vous me
diront le sérieux ou pas lui pas du
pardon donc petit à koh lanta est ce qu
on a vu une candidate de koh lanta avoir
la moustache alors je cautionne pas du
tout le texte à avoir la moustache de
valérie bénaïm les bras j'ai vu
l'extrême et j'ai vu qu'elle doit se
faire comme ça arriver à lui on l'a vu
au cours d'une épreuve
regardez ça va ça a beaucoup fait réagir
[Musique]
alors
elle tue et ça revient à la mode
je suis dans un geste est une nécessité
pas vrai on en parle beaucoup sur les
vignes à des moyens de l'enlever me
disait denis brogniart avec des résines
des trucs comme ça qui tombe bien la
nature mais bon dans les airs
d'ailleurs je ferai un jour ici baisse a
aussi beaucoup fait réagir sur le
réseaux sociaux donnent donc à abbas a
passé sa pensée région voilà voilà rien
avant tu vois là apparemment en 2020
même jeu lorsque tu pars faire une
aventure en mode survie
la pilosité féminine reste un tabou elle
très bien réagit elle à vallabrix y en a
d'autres est ce qu'on a le temps d'en
voir d'autres je ne sais pas oui à la
une femme devrait rester une femme pour
les prochaines candidate penser à
l'épilation définitive avant d'embarquer
en mélodies effectivement il y en a qui
même sans être des ultra féministe aime
bien les poils j'en fais pas partie
merci voilà qui permet soit merci pour
cette analyse denis brogniart voilà qui
permet aux sceptiques très nombreux
chaque année de comprendre que ce koh
lanta il n'a pas d'épilation de
programmes et machet ralink bravo pour
ta victoire ton humour est en recul par
rapport à la repousse des poils et dieu
sait que pose alors est ce qu'on parle
de colonne
ce qu'on parle de koh lanta il ya encore
des choses à dire son koh lanta oui non
support ces panneaux en verre est unie
elle gagne et non moi je suis passé
alors une vitesse folle là dessus un
orgue avec toujours les preuves du
confort on peut regarder ça oui oui
sébastien 28 minutes
[Musique]
c'est aux cinq qui coûterait
avec soin
il est allé au bout de nous-mêmes 34
minutes
depuis le nifff
allez allez l'aider
automoto fabrice félicitations
et c'est donc en avait été une époque
des photos ici et que c'était loin
d'être évident j'ai pas la maille a
lâché pas les photos oui c'est beaucoup
plus difficile pour les mettez le
principe de rester de dôme insiste sur
les masos ça ne fonctionnait tellement
pas l'histoire des régions
ils en sont venus à bout et qu'ils ont
reconstitué deux équipes
c'est un bel honneur caricatural et deux
roues qui était prévu a dévoilé tous en
même temps nathalie ne le suis pas
débile au monde a enregistré sa a été
enregistré au mois de mars donc est ce
que tu veux cleary changé dimanche ben
oui enfin bon oui c'est bon c'est bien
c'est vrai qu'il a enregistrés peuvent
se marier au moment de l'enregistrement
mais c'est pas débile
binoche gellainville non mais dites moi
j'ai juste que ca donne d'être à côté un
nom mais ils voient des complots partout
ils ont adoré
non mais moi j'ai trouvé que c'était
pour le coup un numéro très très réussie
j'ai adoré la réunification l adorer
cette victoire de alix j'ai trouvé qu'on
voyait un bk en or plus solaire lumineux
fédérateur enfin je trouve qu'il est
incroyable et moi j'adore koh lanta je
trouve que ça marche très très bien on
est en tout cas moi je j'adhère voilà
alors l'audience et 5 million cent mille
5 million deux cent mille et plus 1
million en diffusion six jours plus être
là comme on dit maintenant